You should have one goal, to make images look
as beautiful as they can on the user's device, while
using as little bandwidth as possible. Now this last
point is critical. Network bandwidth is most assuredly not free,
particularly on mobile devices. We'll learn more about that
in the next lesson on performance, and in our final
lesson on offline. If you didn't care about bandwidth,
you could just serve massively large images all the time.
But a full screen image for a ChromeBook Pixel
is 4.1 megapixels, whereas on a Nexus 4, it's only
0.9 megapixels. IPhone 5 is only 0.7. The best size
for images is very different on each of these devices.